by the way I took took took some time to
get that man it did take some deal
dealing with people's at how did you
feel about do not like it and I don't
know your world is obviously as well as
you guys do but like do people see and
go turtle and did you want to get away
from that so when they offer you the
movie real like God Damon I'm finally
get away from this turtle thing you know
it's a really I mean I think it's a semi
interesting conversation not even cuz
it's me like I've seen other people sort
of go through it it's like just when
this the because we had the luxury of
actually knowing when entourage was
gonna end like we knew in like season
five or going eight years sorry and then
we're done so timing out with the fact
that I got in shape I had all this time
to like start to get away from the show
and I was actually doing pretty well for
me i dun't three or four movies i was i
was getting in rooms it was like okay we
broke it a little bit it's sort of going
it'll never go away but it's it's
decreasing like I was starting to look
at me as Jerry and not the guy from I
then when the movie comes up it's like
if I'm I'm being honest and I i even
told doug ellin this and and Steve
Levinson is like do we really want to do
this it's been like four years it
depended on such a good note I thought
yeah I feel like it was a bad timing
part no no disrespect in but a lot of
things have changed too since the show
yeah when it came out is like a man
how'd the movie do it definitely did not
meet expectations yeah it was not
considered like a flop failure or
anything but it was if you would have
asked you know some of the people
involved making you with a thought for
sure the movie would have did
exponentially better than it did I think
that's the high but it's like the
friends doing a [ __ ] reunion movie
that's what I saw what I gillum's had a
tough time replicating any of that
success I think anybody would yes yeah
of course so much of it also is
lightning in a bottle well man cuz we
didn't really even know we were doing in
those first cuz chemist you were around
it to like it we're figuring out as it
went first two years not many people
were watching the show and then season
three just something happen boom and
everyone would not everyone but a lot
was very with you yeah I remember the
reason I asked about that whole turtle
thing and try and get away from
because pivens our buddy the only good
friend yeah and Pittman was saying how
uh he's talking to this girl at dinner
and she's like guy I thought you were me
an [ __ ] excuse me she was yeah you
know like like re goalies like it's a
character then I'm playing a role yeah
check please you know it's like what and
so for its what for him especially like
people think he's that intense like Ari
Gold and he's far from it right I really
well Jeremy was smart as he just he went
to another country he left starting to
he's starting another Alfred let's shake
a little pretty anymore up yeah I'm
gonna go over there and do that and I'm
gonna take a break and i'll be back like
that that's why i thought because for
you like I saw him about last night
which I loved about last night to all
that stuff and then the ink goes back to
ya i'm sure you'll age was like I mean
listen you can do it man it's emotion he
is the problem with it's like and I
really did resist it to a degree there
was all these talks like oh who's
slowing it down it's not that I was
slowing it down it really became about
the business part of it it's like hey if
we're gonna do this I'm not saying we're
just doing it for money that's not ever
why you just do anything to me anyway
you have to have some sort of enjoyment
doing it but you know we have to make
sure that if this doesn't go well or
doesn't go right which it didn't
necessarily go right that it was at
least worth the risk because it is a
risk at that point for all of us to go
back in sure and play those characters
again that I'm not it'll never go away
but like i said i was doing alright and
I'm still doing alright but yeah it took
a minute to after we did the movie to
kind of reset again you gotta you gotta
hit that reset button again I only got
so many of those in me for sure there's
so many many button right there are so
many examples of people that come off a
show like that and never work again or
is never the same it's and that's why I
was thinking about it you and Jeremy are
the only guys and it's not it's not a
knock on anybody cuz I I think Kevin
Connolly is great oh yank on heaven soon
yeah he's doing his own thing yeah I'm
glad he's doing all cuz he's smart no
he's doing well he's like directing he's
actually owns the rights the cages my
system very it's a very weird business
is all I'm saying and you just for a
thousand reasons things can either work
really well if they they don't work out
perception is reality
unfortunate like you're talking about
Jeremy like I literally feel like I've
disappointed fans of entourage when they
meet me in real life because they expect
yo let's go smoke a blunt and listen to
music in the car your cats and [ __ ]
yeah yeah y'all we're going outside my
dog I I live with my girlfriend fly
throw in the bed 1030 night yeah it's
gotta be disappointing people for years
to character yeah he's a caring idiot it
was a lot more like that around the time
I was 21 22 when I'm sure about here I
know who that dude is but uh yeah Joe
Frazier's jockstrap unwashed mind you is
being auctioned off from the from the
ollie fight of the century fight bet
your sweet ass it is for how much take a
guess I mean Ollie just how much did you
pay for an unwashed jockstrap from
another man oh yeah nothing but the fact
that you're bringing it up I mean I'm
gonna hit it at 20 grand but I'm being
redic it at 2056 minute it's or i think
it's a it's expected to sell for 10
grand it was expected to sell for 10
grand but it it met its five grand like
Mike minimum marker in the first like
six out well if you buy that what we
gonna like triple I don't wanna end up
being is somewhere around like 15 grand
I'll tell you right now latara if you
buy that and I go to your house for a
house party its frame I'm probably leave
bra can't be friends anymore man why
yeah you bought a other man's jockstrap
me framed it yeah and you're proud of it
that's hilarious Jim your friend anymore
if some guy like that and then wants me
to come look at it you're right I'm
gonna go yeah that's a little weird
can't be your friend don't call them
anymore there's no more bbqs nothing
that it knows it so you want you're not
gonna be thrown in a bid for the
jockstrap then there's not a man that
has ever been born on this planet that
I'd pay money for his use Junction my
own I'm not keeping my own dirty jet
that's gross there's a reason I wash it
at the end of practice right it's weird
oh this is funny my John Jones maybe a
second or third fight we're training
together I'd be traced Gormley in 47
seconds he was the main event against I
think either mad a shame
go Brandon fair in Broomfield Colorado
he forgot his jockstrap and tights I
beat the brakes off my guy 47 seconds i
come back and he's i shop i need your
jockstrap mamak what because i need you
jocks i'm like why the [ __ ] do you he's
my jockstrap he's like I don't have one
all right caped him there it was my
favorite pair this under armour one
never got him back yeah but you know
time you desperation you'll wear jock
strap she can't fight without it Chris
Camozzi one time we're on a CD I could
do and we had just met the world small
we cut weight the day before in the Sun
I seemed next a go I need your jock and
[ __ ] I was like and I'm never giving it
he's like no you're not you're not
giving it back I'm like thank you buddy
uh chill have you had the itch to fight
again recently ah man I think about it
all the time I um I wrestled in college
and I will tell you there one match
specifically but matches in general I'll
be driving around in my car thinking
about fantasizing to go back to go in
that moment and I've talked to fighters
that have retired and I guess that's
just the way your life's gonna go from
now you probably do that with football
MMA I mean you know with that athletic
like don't do you do that with the show
at all if you ever hope go home and any
guy I could've done even better on the
show oh I should have done every time
yeah everybody i do the same thing so i
think it's like wait he's got to come to
terms with it but to answer the question
candidly yeah me and I think about all
times so if your suspensions up and
frickin a few thing gets up i think i'm
off right so if you're off you in the
UFC called you'd fight no i would not
know i am all done but all you're done
that i do think about it i do fantasize
about it and you know i was just a UFC
200 right the arenas packed this is
brand-new and you get you jealous i'm
jang enjoying the show but at the same
time thing man i'd love to be part of
that so i can see that i like to the big
cards like man be cool to be involved
with that and i had a business
opportunity with Bellator they flew me
out it was the phil davis and King mo
card and I brought my brother and I met
with Coker did all this stuff and I said
to myself right if I get to the arena
cuz I've been in a life flight since my
last fight against Travis Browne two
years ago for many reasons so I said
when I if I get in there and it hits me
you know I can figure some stuff out the
OCLC I'm under contract them I could
fight whenever I want and I got there
and they walk you through the back
locker rooms because Phil and I are
close in King mo and I was like no no
hell no once i get them personally no
way man and i went through that as well
I remember when I when I very first uh
why I thought Anderson Silva second time
I lost and I remember thinking I'm
probably not going to do this sport
anymore and I went home to Portland and
there was a strike for school and I went
live and this is like four days after
five days after I fought boom it's a
very next friday and tim kennedy and
rock hill were fighting i remember
watching the case i just going I can't
believe I ever did this and only been
five days it's like I can't believe I
ever did this let alone want to do it
again up and then some more time went by
next thing I know did you know you get
the itch goes the other way but I
understand yeah we're saying it's weird
because because is my man's like when
you retire man you know you can only say
you're retired and come back and I was
like yeah it's a loose statement i'll do
that may be bak kut to 205 with this new
diet blah blah there's just it's just
not there for me man and that's so
dangerous yeah it's so dangerous but
then there's your answer right then
there's your answer yeah he was like
trying to want to do it don't do it if I
could give any any advice to anyone not
even doing music which is that's going
out putting themselves out in front of
people you know on a public scale going
to be a public figure I think the key to
the key to success is being yourself I
mean like if I feel like human beings
subconsciously could look at another
human being just be like that dudes
being authentic yeah i mean like sure i
might not i might not vibe with it might
not be my thing but that guy's that's
him you know and i think that's why you
can never look bad when you're really
honest are really really vulnerable
vulnerable it's it's interesting because
when you kind of go look man even when
people really [ __ ] up like when they
even when they really [ __ ] up and they
say something like yeah I did it and I
feel really that's what i want to say
with jon jones i dunno if you guys
follow you see what jon jones right yeah
cheese yeah he should just get on the
mic like alright man I'm [ __ ] 27 28 on
the greatest fighter of all time when
they the night before they came to test
me I was ball
deep and some girl doing lines off this
girls titties we want me to take home a
bass dude in the world right I thought
that followed up take me back in two
years when Tiger Woods was leading that
statement I was like stop put that
[ __ ] thing down and say this hey guys
I was the most famous golfer in the
world I've had to be perfect my entire
life I had the best-looking women in the
world throwing themselves at me I also
have the personality of this little but
I don't know how to do this I don't know
how to be this way and I have no further
and I and I and I I'm gonna try to be
better I'm gonna try to be better I
cheat on my wife a lot I committed gross
infidel onil I actually felt guilty but
I really liked it that's the truth I'm
not saying I admire myself I'm
embarrassed in a shame mainly because of
my kids but I'm gonna try to be better
and then I would say hey fellas try
being me and not [ __ ] slang and the
small agent dick exact [ __ ] you know
it's not it's surhoff it's me out ok
been correct don't say some front you're
being stereotypical there's half ways
half black eye yeah yeah dad was met you
guys really have no that's one guy you
have no idea what I've heard he's got
I've heard he's got he's working with
something